[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
in situ single cell transcriptomic
imaging in formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded ffpe tissues with
merscope i am marie stone of labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by visgen
to learn more visit visgen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
any questions as we have time for at the
end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
jiang her co-founder and director of
scientific affairs vizgen
zhang you may now begin your
presentation
thank you so much for the introduction
and hello everyone my name is jiang
today i'm super excited to share our
latest progress in single cell spatial
genomics and specifically in situ single
cell transcriptomic imaging in ffp
samples
so for today's presentation i'm going to
cover two topics
first i will give an overview of our
platform technology and then i will
explain our recent advancement in
imaging ffp samples with merscope
as many of us know biological tissues
are very complex and made of many
different cell types that express genes
quite differently and over the past two
or three decades sequencing has
transformed our understanding of biology
and really enabled us to characterize
biological systems at unprecedented
scale and resolution
however
as you can imagine sequencing has
fundamental limitations
it is difficult to use bulk or single
cell sequencing to infer where
individual cells are or how they
interact with each other and our
understanding of biological systems are
thereby far from complete
in recent years a new field called
spatial genomics emerged
which really aims to add the critical
special component back to the picture
and we especially resolve single cell
genomics we are now witnessing another
revolution in genomics research
and as the company winston is bringing
the first true single cell special
transcriptomic platform called merscope
to the market
merscope is built based on foundation
technology called murfish which enables
simultaneous imaging of hundreds to
thousands of different genes in a single
round with high sensitivity and accuracy
it can also scan very large imageable
area up to one square centimeter with
very fine special resolution and no
downstream need of sequencing so this is
the all in one user-friendly solution
which includes the upscreen sample prep
related reagents instrument and
downstream visualization software
highlighted here on this slide is the
instrument that performs data
acquisition and data analysis
and in the next few slides i'm going to
walk you through the principles of
murfish technology first
so murphy stands for multiplexed aero
robust fluorescence in situ
hybridization it is built based upon a
rna imaging technology called single
monarchy fish and as shown on this night
to perform some fish rna transcripts of
interest are labeled by fluorescence
detect oligoprobes and by directly
counting the number of rna species that
fluoresces we can then really determine
the profile expression profile for each
individual gene as you can see from the
image on the right
so sm fish is very well known for its
sensitivity and often considered as the
gold standard for quantifying rna copy
numbers
the limitation for sm fish however is
that the plexi level is very limited
often less than five
and to overcome this big limitation
murphy implements a novel
complementary barcoding scheme that
really enables um simultaneous imaging
of hundreds to thousands of different
rna species
so i'm going to use this schematic here
on the slide to illustrate how murfish
works
to perform murfish we will first assign
a set of buccals to different genes of
interest
i'm using gene 1 on this side to
illustrate the principle here we will
first label the target rna species with
a type of oligopole that contains
different buckles you can see that it
has a targeting region that will be able
to bind to different rna species and
also has the handout that has readout
sequences
then we are going to flow in a subset of
readout probes that is fluorescence
detect and then it will bind to its
corresponding
readout sequences on the handout region
and if there is a body event then it
will show up as a fluorescent on signal
and then it would decode as one
and if there is no fluorescent signal
then it will decode as zero and then we
will extinguish the signal and then flow
in another subset of fluorescency label
readout probes again
and then again you can see in the second
round uh if there is a binding event
there is a fluorescent signal and then
it will
decode as one and then if there is no
signal then it would decode as zero so
essentially by repeating this cycle
we're building a series of ones and
zeros
and by matching with the predesigned
barcode then it really allows us to now
to resolve the identity as well as the
quantity of different rna species
so this barcode scheme is further
designed with error robustness because
we only use a small subset of buckle in
the available buckle space and barcode
sequences actually also have enough
space in between so incorrect assigning
a barcode is very unlikely
um so if there is a readout error this
system can actually
detect and correct it to the nearest
barcode and that's what's making merkel
so accurate and consistent
so with this complementary labeling
sequential round of imaging and
aerobatic barcoding murphy's really
enables researchers to now directly
visualize gene expression in situ as you
can see from this animation here you can
zoom in
and zoom out to really see the gene
expression from whole tissue to single
cell and even subcellular resolution
so there are a couple of key advantages
of mrs platform and i'm going to sort of
walk you through one by one the first
one is that it is a truly quantitative
measurement across a very large dynamic
range of gene expression profile
so on this night what you are seeing
here is the comparison of murphy's data
uh acquired in the mouse brain tissue
with bulgarian sequencing
and each dot represented gene uh the
y-axis you see in the copy number per
cell counted by murfish and x-axis you
have seen the spk values from both rna
sequencing
so you can see that in general murfish
has excellent correlation with rna-seq
with correlation coefficient around 0.88
and this linear range is spanning more
than four orders magnitude
so this large range is very important to
uh not not expressed genes to be
accuracy profiles if you look at this
not only we can profile genes at high
speak and value but also lower spk value
very accurately
so the second key feature of former
scope is that it has exceptional high
detection efficiency
so as i mentioned before sm fish is
often considered as the gold standard
for quantifying iron copy numbers and
has single molecule sensitivity
another technology field based on s and
fish mersco maintains that high
sensitivity of sm fish
so on this side i'm showing you the
comparison of performance between
microscope and array-based spatial
genomics platform in mass brain samples
so this is measuring hundreds of genes
in the mouse brain and for the same
genes measures oh i'm showing a single
one here called oprd1 this is a gtcr you
can clearly see where this gene is
distributed in the mouse frame
however if you look at the image at the
bottom with the array based platform you
only see a couple grid spots
and as you zoom in into individual field
of views with
more scope you can clearly see which
individual cell expressed in opr31 on
the other hand when we look at the image
on the at the bottom with the
array-based platform since the grid spot
size is around 55 microns and in between
there's a lot of depth space thereby you
don't really have any true single cell
resolution
and when we compare these two datasets
we consistency found that merscope has
70 times detects 70 times more
transcripts per gene versus the
array-based platform
so just really think about the
difference in sensitivity here and how
much information you were actually
lost if you use a technology that
doesn't really capture much of the rna
transcript
the third key feature i wanted to
highlight is that merscope really
features true in-situ detection at
single cell resolution
so our platformer scope uses high na 60x
objective to capture all the images with
imaging resolution down to 100
nanometers
thereby it offers two single cell
resolution and by combining
immunofluorescence to label the boundary
merscope enables true cell adolescence
so in this cancer cell paper published
last year in 2021 for example the
authors used murphy's to characterize
different cell types in glioblastoma
so as you can see from the heat map in
the middle
so this is showing the gene expression
profile in the identified cell types you
can see that murfish was able to really
recapitulate the gene expression
features in the identified cell types it
almost looks
identical to the single cell rna
characterization valve
but since murphy is in situ measurement
it does offer information that single
cell rna6 cannot provide and this is
enables the researchers now to study the
interaction of macrophages to subtypes
of cancer cells and specifically they
measure the mean number of macrophages
in 30 nearest
cells to the mbs microglial plastoma
cells and specifically they found the
enrichment of macrophages adjacent to
this subtype of glioblastoma cells in
situ
so
you can imagine that such finance really
demonstrates that the power of enc2
single cell transcriptomic profiling to
uncover and really characterize cell
cell interaction because without this
such a finding will almost be impossible
purely based on the single cell rna-seq
analysis
finally merciful features extremely high
cells throughput
and as the image-based technology the
number of cells profiled is directly
related to the tissue area image
it is very easy for microscope to scale
up the cell structure by turning more
regions of interest to image
and specifically our merscope is
supposed profiling a square centimeter
size of tissue with hundreds of thousand
cells can be captured in a single run
so for example on this knife we use
smart scopes to profile 483 genes across
the mouse frame uh and what you're
seeing here on the right in the zoom
million is a single field of view each
single field of view is 200 by 200
microns and we tied hundreds to even
thousands of images to
capture of the whole brand section
and what's really nice about this system
is that no follow-up sequencing is
needed um you get all the information
from an imaging rom
so the technology has been around for a
number of years now uh it was invented
by our scientific co-founder dr xiaowei
juan at harvard university back in 2015
and since the initial publication in the
journal of science it has been validated
by non-listed publications now and
brought many transformative discoveries
and across the globe there are already
many institutions using murphish others
through their own implementation or
services commercial efforts
so murphy's has been widely used in many
disease areas now and in the next two
slides i'm going to highlight two
studies here for example dr ben
hampersnap at washington university at
st louis used the merscope to profile 10
of 240 street genes in mount kidney an
adjacent kidney slide was provided by
array-based platform
and on the side i'm highlighting one
gene called slc 12a1 here so this is the
kidney specific sodium potassium
chloride called transporter
and hopefully by just looking at these
two pictures uh on the slide you can see
the striking difference in terms of the
detection efficiency and resolution you
can
with the array-based platform you only
see a couple of grid spots while with
merscope you can clearly see where slc
12a1 express and the elaborate structure
is labeling in the mass kidney
so in other words the high detection
efficiency and resolution provided by
mercury really enables spatial profiling
of genes inaccessible by other special
technologies that is available on the
market at the moment
see in a separate study uh published in
science back in 2018 uh murphy's was
used to profile 155 genes for a total of
almost half a million cells in the mouse
hypothetical region and the authors were
able to identify 75 cell clusters in
this brain region
so this is shown in the teasing plot
here you can see all the major cell
classes labeled in different colors
and
in this paper the authors also also
perform performed single-star
organisation and benchmarked the
performance of murphy versus single-star
and sick
and again you can see quantitatively
murfish agrees very well with
single-star rna-seq all the major cells
have spawned by single-star organistic
were recapitulated by murphy's
measurement as you can see from this
correlation plot here
so as the cell position information is
recorded in this measurement murphy
further helped reveal the cell
organization in mouse tissue as well so
showing here in the middle now these
colorful dots indicate different cell
classes identified by murfish and from
anterior to posterior i hope you can
really see how different cells are
distributed in this brain region now
and furthermore by including genes that
can report a neural activity and in this
specific case the authors included gene
called c4s
so they were able to really selectively
identify neural types that are activated
during individual social behaviors such
as parenting behaviors or mating
behaviors for example showing here this
bar represents the neuronal type that is
selectively active during parenting
behaviors and with the spatial
information recorded in this measurement
you can now map out where those
individual cells are now in complex
tissue so this study really highlights
the power of murphy's to perform true
cell adolescence and to map cell types
characterize their function and state in
the complex tissue
so within wisdom we are keep pushing the
limits of the technology by expanding
the application areas we have proven
murphy's in more than 30 different
mouths or tissues or human tissue types
now and compatible sample types
demonstrated so far include cultured
cells fresh frozen fixed frozen tissue
blocks and shown here on this night you
can see a couple of examples of
different tissues we imaged in mouse or
human
however there is a big question
unanswered
can mersco be used in fft samples which
is one of the most widely used clinical
sample types
so in the second half of my presentation
i'm going to focus on discussing merge
scope imaging in ffp samples
and to give some context of why this
application is very important i'm going
to use this slide to illustrate the pros
and cons of different tissue
preservation methods um so as you can
see here
so fresh frozen tissues could really
preserve dna or rna better and
it could even be compatible with single
cell sequencing analysis
however
the tissue blocks usually need to be
stored at -80 and this is a very costly
solution and often not available for
clinical
practices on the other hand ffp or
so-called hormonally fixed pair of
embedded samples
so they are widely available and it
could preserve the tissue morphology
better
and around the world they are banks of i
cover ffp samples um so if it can really
unlock the use of these fft samples it
will uh really enable and
in more and more new discoveries made in
the um
in biology however there are challenges
of actually working and perform single
cell analysis with ffp samples for
example heavy cross linking can make it
very difficult to access the rnas
instead of sfp sample and separately rna
tends to be
more fragmented in ffb samples
and these challenges really require a
substantial change of workflow in order
to perform single-cell spatial genomic
measurement in ffp samples
so to overcome these challenges at
western we have developed a new
preparatory chemistry to facilitate
miracle imaging in sop samples
and this is based on our first
generation frozen protocol the measure
changed our sample prep workflow and
thereby it is compatible with existing
mercury platform and our portfolio
products
so to evaluate the performance of this
technology
we have chosen sfp mouse brand for
merscope imaging because
it has very well annotated in c2g
expression profile and thereby we can
more accurately evaluate the performance
of our chemistry in detail
so showing here is a 483 gym panel
imaging in the ffp mouse frame
and all the detected transcripts are
shown across the tissue and in the
middle you are also seeing a zoom the
single field of view showing the
distribution of all transcripts at
single cell resolution
so overall we were able to detect around
45 million transcripts in around 55 000
cells in these single measurements and
the mean transcript counts per cell is
around 816.
so this is comparable to our fresh
frozen data that's released publicly so
um if you're interested we actually have
a data release program that has the
mouse brain receptor map released and um
this is
something that you will be able to
download from our website and it's using
the same gene panel uh to perform the
benchmark input in the ffp study here
so furthermore the genes profile by
merscope show expected special
distribution in the ffp mouse brand as
well so showing here at the bottom um
i'm showing 4gs gf ap cnr1 drd2 and adgr
a1 provided by mercure or by other
institutes in situ hybridization so
hopefully you can really see that for
all four genes um it has
the expected spatial distribution
pattern very nicely captured by merscope
so this really speaks that the new
chemistry is working very well and
next to most systematically characterize
the performance of merscope ffp workflow
we started to perform a couple
benchmarking
to really characterize its performance
uh so we benchmark to be acquired
definitely in ffp without rnseek and
murphy's data acquired by fresh frozen
workflow
so as shown by this correlation thought
here um we spoke around a sick
ffp workflow is highly quantitative
and with correlation coefficient of 0.88
and you can see that
it also maintains the linear correlation
with a very large dynamic range of
expression more than four orders of
magnitude similar to the range that i
discussed a few nights ago
so this is also highly reproducible
measurements and in biological
replicates we almost see perfect
correlation here as you can see from
this correlation plot almost with
correlation coefficient around 1.
so furthermore when we compare the count
detected by ffp workflow in ffp samples
versus those that are detected by fresh
frozen product in fresh frozen samples
we also found excellent correlation with
correlation coefficient around 0.95
so furthermore merscope's high special
resolution allows two cell athletes and
we are able to really perform
the cell type identification and using
these it really allows us to now
characterize can we recapitulate the
cell types identified by fresh frozen
workflow in fft samples or not so i'm
going to play a short video here uh
showing here is the umap identified by
this kind of 483 genes and then this
animation is going to show the spatial
distribution of all the different cell
types identified by ffpe workflow at the
top or the freshwater frozen workflow
and as we're
looking at different leading clusters i
hope you can really appreciate how sfp
workflow is able to recalculate all the
major cell types identified by our fresh
frozen workflow
see in a short summary here it looks
like our fft workflow announced very
large dynamic range of expression
profiles for profile genes more than
four orders of magnitude it is highly
sensitive and accurate measurement and
comparable performance to fresh frozen
workflow as well
so
having established the performance in
the um sort of our benchmarking sample
mouse frame next we wonder if merscope
ffp workflow can be used in other tissue
types other than mouse brain or not
and since most ffp samples are coming
from human samples we next tested the
samples you know the human colon cancer
with a pen of 244 genes
and in this single slice we were able to
detect 135 million copies
and again as you can see from the
picture here uh i had a 17th uh here ac
ta2 which um labels the smooth small
mass after cd1 63 macro phase marker p
cam then the serial marker keratin
museum and tgf better you can clearly
see the very beautiful structure that
these genes are highlighted in the colon
cancer
we also bench
benchmark performance versus bulk rna
sequencing and as you can see here
this each each individual gene
are indicated in this blue dot here and
the y-axis is the murphy counts and
accesses our secant values
and you can see the correlation
coefficient of 0.81 here
so to demonstrate the wide applicability
of merkle uh in uh
in the other samples we decided to
perform more scope imaging in more than
ten different samples uh i'm showing
here um so again we were sort of really
extracting the correlation coefficient
with the correlation plot here uh
similar to this value i'm showing here
and just apply all the correlation
coefficients with balcony in a bar chart
for more than 10 different sample types
including breast cancer colon cancer
kidney
pancreas stomach
and such and you can really see that
across all the samples it all has very
accident correlation
so the
miroscope
fft workflow is compatible with proteins
called staining as well so on this night
we performed six protein imaging um
together with a panel of 347 gene panel
measurements um so on the left you're
seeing three out of the six proteins
here um pencil ck sma uh e-calcium and
on the right you'll see the distribution
of all transcripts and in this
measurement around 70 70 million counts
were detected with a pair of 347 genes
and at the bottom i'm zooming into one
specific region and on the left again
you see this very beautiful staining
down by the protein pens ck sma and the
category and on the right you see in the
overlay of all transcripts on top of the
protein standing
so having established the performance of
merscope in different samples next um in
the next few slides i'm going to
showcase a couple of studies that was
performed in fft samples and the first
one
is to really map the tumor marker
environment in ffp human ovarian cancer
so this was done by using a panel of 500
genes and in this single slice i'm
highlighting only eight genes here um so
in this measurement we were able to
detect
174 million rna transcripts and
hopefully you can really see the
beautiful special
distribution of these eight selected
genes here and to really illustrate what
the data quality looks like i'm going to
zoom into the data and show you two
animations here on this knife
so first i'm going to zoom into this
ovarian cancer i'm only highlighting
these eight genes here then i'm turning
on 500 genes and further zoom in and
hopefully you can see the distribution
of individual transports at a single
cell level and then i'm zooming out now
and then turn off this 500 only showing
eight rna transcript
and hopefully you can really see how the
data looks like from across the tissue
down to single cell resolution
so since we were able to perform cell
boundary standing which is antibody
based that allows us to segment the
cells and perform single cell analysis
so on the right we basically identified
different cell types and projected them
in a new map and then
also show the spatial distribution of
identified cell types in space as well
so hopefully in this um animation here
you can clearly see how different cell
types where different cell types are
distributed so it purely sticks the
power of uc markov ffc workflow to sort
of perform
cell athletes in complex tissue like
cancer
so next uh miroscope was used to imagine
archival ffp human melanoma samples and
this was profiling a panel of 244 four
genes and this sample was more than five
years old
and uh on the top left uh i only
highlighted six selected genes out of
these 244 g measurements of um for
example ac ta2 labelling smooth smok
amount active cd4 for the t cells cd4 t
cells and cd79b for the b cells keratin
labeled in the epidermis here and
hopefully you can really see the
beautiful structure that these genes are
highlighted in here
and on the top right two images this is
showing the antibodies standing for the
cell boundaries um hopefully you can
really see the very nicely defined cell
boundary using our cell boundary kit and
with that it allows us to really segment
individual cells so
on the this image here you're showing
you're seeing the polygon shapes draw on
top of the cells uh draw by our default
documentation algorithm
so again this allows us to now uh sort
of identify different cell types and
perform your map clustering
and you can see the different clusters
here and then we were able to project
these different cell types in space
and i'm highlighting three different
cell types here for example cd4 t cells
and the cydia cells and keratinocytes
are in the melanoma so show you really
really unique distribution here
and in this measurement actually
156 million rna transcripts were
detected
so the last example that i'm showing
here is microscope imaging in ffp human
noun and on the left i'm showing the
spatial distribution of uh
five selected genes called ac ta2 ager
and macrophage marker ddr1633
museum and spf tl a2
so we were also able to perform cell
clustering um as well and project the
identified cells in space so these
different colored dots now what you're
seeing is the identified cell types are
in the human noun so overall we were
able to detect 70 million rna
transcripts in this human noun size
and in this zoom the image here i can
hopefully you can see for example
these new symbol positive cells enabling
the bronchial surrounded by uh the hdta2
positive fibroblasts then you can see
the magenta the macrophage and then you
see the type 1 and type 2 cells labeled
by agr and sf pa2 here as well
so overall we have demonstrated more
scope image gm15
ffp sample types and here are a few
representative microscope images on
different tissue types for example human
lymph node tonsils non-cancer skin and
kidney and i hope really these images
illustrate the special architecture of
different tissue types and how important
it is to have a really highly sensitive
and versatile tool to provide
inspiration and cell types
and around the globe there have been
researchers already adopting merscope
ffp workflow in the research for example
the pharmaceutical company computing in
israel used mercury to study the immune
tumor market environment in common and
ovarian cancer
and in broad institute near hakone's
group is using this to study the colon
cancer spore and these are some of the
posters that they have recently been
presenting
so i also want to mention that uh wisdom
has a data release program and we have
released two data sets so on this night
this is a recent mouse lever data set of
measuring
347 genes more than one billion
transcripts and we're actually going to
have ffp showcase data released coming
soon as well so if you're interested um
so please do sign up this uh data
release program
and to recap what i have just shared uh
today so here is a quick summary of
merkel advantages
first miroscope has high multiplexing
power but we can measure hundreds to
thousands of genes simultaneously in a
single sample and our default offering
is calcium gene panels and it also is
compatible with
protein imagine as well
secondly mr scoop has exceptional
special resolution we can localize rna
with subcellular resolution and this
high resolution is preserved across the
entire tissue
third miroscope has highest sensitivity
for detecting i
identify different rna species and
it really enables us to detect low
expressed but functionally important
genes very easily
and furthermore meroscope has very high
cells throughput uh we can profile a
square centimeter size to tissue uh with
hundreds of thousands cells measured in
a single experiment with no downstream
sequence needed so you basically get all
the information from a single image and
run
and finally merge will be very flexible
and we can perform most of almost all
t-shirt or sample type
so in summary i hope this presentation
gives you a good overview of merger
platform and how we can actually perform
sop imaging uh immersive imaging in ffp
samples and we're truly excited about
the potential of our technology and we'd
love to hear how we could potentially
help with your research as well so with
that i wanted to thank you
for your attention and
and if you have um
have any questions please let me know or
send any inquiries to the email address
below thank you
thank you zhang for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what is the recommended rna quality for
a sample
uh yeah so for uh
fresh frozen or fixed frozen samples uh
we use uh rna integrity number ring
score as a garden line for
sample qc and
for frozen samples ring
the best to be above seven uh in between
five to seven it also will give good uh
good data but it may have some
compromise to quality
so we know four we don't usually
recommend for frozen samples
on the other hand for ffp samples we use
a different metrics to evaluate our
inequality which is
called db200 value
and
so far we have mostly worked with
samples above forty percent at the 200
value so that that will be so so far our
current guideline
thank you
next question
do you need a different instrument
um so to work with ffp samples you don't
need a additional instrument so the
major changes are the um sample prep
steps so everything happens on bench and
you can use the same gene panel the same
instrument to work in ffp to work with
ffp samples
thank you
next question
how long is the target probe
yes our target profile around 30
nucleotides per probe um so yeah
okay
next question
is it possible to use this technology
with non-human and non-my samples
uh yes absolutely um so
we actually already have early adopters
using miroscope on rats uh monkey
samples and there are even some groups
uh trying plants um so
that's not there's an annotated
transcription available
we will be able to design probes against
those rna species and then perform more
fish
thank you
next question
what is the maximum area that can be
measured per experiment does it always
cover a full coronal section or only
sub-area is preferred
so yeah on merscope the
total image area is up to one square
centimeter so this image by area is
actually larger than the chrono section
of the mouse brand that showed here i'd
say to put into context
that one square centimeter is probably
one and a half whole chrono section of
the mouse brain uh if it's the right in
the middle of the nine of the vegeta
essentia to a brain region it may
be just covering around one square
centimeter so so you need it will be
able to cover the full coronal section
and even provide that there are still
some extra
rise that you can select for other
tissues if needed
thank you
next question
can you combine merscope with regular
histology such as visualizing innate gfp
or antibody staining prior to murfish
uh yes absolutely so um
to image gfp
signal what we usually do is to use an
antibody
and against the gfp and then use
oligoconjugated secondary antibodies to
recognize that so it's possible and you
don't need to
write on adjacent side you can do the
antibody staining on
the exactly same size
great thank you
next question
is the proprietary prep chemistry for
ffpe destructive that is can the tissues
uh use for sequencing can the tissues be
used for sequencing or other downstream
techniques after merscope
yes so um after the murphy system uh
so in the sample
the final process sample what's left
behind is usually the dna and rna and
oligos thereby for downstream sequencing
you can actually take
uh whatever is left in the sample and
then do the downstream sequencing so
internally we have not usually performed
that kind of downstream sequencing but
we believe this is possible
thank you
next question
ffpe has high autofluorescence
how does murfish overcome that
yes so um
we actually have developed our own
method to remove autofluorescence and
this is not just related to ffpe but
also to the
fresh frozen or fixed frozen sample
types for example like across
a different a variety of different human
tissues even in fresh frozen states
it will have some autofluorescence um
and within our product we do have two
different approaches of removing the
autofluorescence step one is in our uh
autofluorescence quenching step um and
then the other one is our tissue
clearance step
thank you
next question
how many proteins maximum can be
detected together with rna
yeah so for a protein co-staining and
imaging our merscope this is actually
some of a product that westerners
company will be releasing in the coming
months so it's coming to the market very
soon so this is our
audio conjugated secondary antibodies
and it will be able to support a max up
to six protein co-staining um so a
researcher can choose whatever primary
antibody coming from this different host
species and then use
the secondary antibody for protein code
detection
thank you
next question
where can we download the data sets
so um if you go to our website there
will be a data release program so far
there are two data sets
available one is the mouse brand
receptor data system the second one is
the mouse neighbor datasets we will be
posting our ffpe datasets which covers
quite a few different cancer types using
a gene panel of 500 genes and it has
many it's basically our immune oncology
panel where you will see a lot of immune
cell markers
cancer cell markers um and checkpoint
inhibitor and the receptors and
cytokines and such
um
they are in this stream panel so if you
if you go to our
website and register for that um it will
receive notifications for the next data
release and
uh after this um
we will actually continue to roll out
more data coming from different tissue
types so uh
if you work in a different research area
also i would highly recommend you to
look for that resource as we continue to
run more
data all right
next question
when will the merscope ffpe be available
so the ffp sample prep
kits will be released
later in the year on you know few months
i'd say around history um this year
hey thank you
next question
do current panel design do current
panels designed for fresh tissue work
with the ffpe samples
uh yes so the gym panel used for frozen
samples
the same gene panel can be used on
ffp samples but you don't really need to
redesign a gene panel
thank you
next question
have you tried merscope in ffpe human
brain tissue
yes so we have tried both fresh frozen
and ffp human brain and both works very
well
next question
can you detect non-coding or non-poly a
transcripts in ffpe
uh
so
that is something that we have not very
rigorously looked at yet um so for
non-coding rnas murphy has been
demonstrated to be able to detect um so
our new chemistry will be able to detect
sort of noun poly a
uh tell mrna for sure um so um but
we haven't specifically looked for the
genes in that category though um but we
believe our chemistry will be able to uh
to address and look for
topics of that kind
thank you
next question
with the neuroblastoma tissues we see
high fluorescence how do you take care
of the autofluorescence
yeah i think this is a great question
and really relates to the previous uh
background question uh asked before so
indeed in brain
lipofusion and such is one of the major
concerns and causes a lot of background
and the two steps that are mentioned um
the autofluorescence quenching and
clearing uh in general can help remove
all the backgrounds and you can actually
if you're interested in seeing how these
performance you can go to our website
and download our tech note we do have a
session on how to address the auto
fluorescence background
thank you
the max what uh next question
what what is the maximal number of genes
to be identified in one tissue sample
with murfish theoretically
so
so far the highest number demonstrated
through academic publication from our
scientific co-founder dr charway drawn's
lab
is more than 10 000 genes in cells and
recently uh her lab also published a
posted about paper demonstrated human
brain imaging with 4 000 genes in tissue
so that's the number that has been
demonstrated so far in publication
all right
next question
i have heart tissue fixed with four
percent pfa and was embedded in paraffin
can i use these samples for merscope
uh yes so the uh ffpe
sample prep
histology process is actually very
standard of
protocol so we don't really have any
harsh requirement of how the tissue
should be fixed or how it should be
embedded in paraffin
so this is compatible
thank you next question
when photo bleaching the ffpe sections
is there a risk of disintegrating the
tissue section
any measures that will need to be taken
so for
removing the autofluorescence using our
autoflower sequential device uh we
actually when uh we compare this in our
frozen samples we don't really um see a
major impact without or without using
this in
certain samples that doesn't have
autofluorescence so we don't believe
it's disrupting the
uh the topics inside the tissue
thank you
next question what's the maximum
thickness of ffpe sections for murfish
so for now we generally recommend
basically uh what the uh
immunohistochemistry field ihc if you
usually do which is four micron thick or
five micron thick but
if you wanted to go slightly thicker it
is also possible so this is a little bit
different from the frozen tissue frozen
tissue people generally cut around 10
micron thick
ffp in the field usually it's cutting
four to 5 micron 6. so we are basically
following the general gardener in the
ihc field
thank you
and we will wrap up with that final
question
thank you again zhong for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab routes and
our sponsor viz gen for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
you